Cette semaine je reçois une nouvelle invitée, elle était déjà venue vous apprendre à vous palper les seins
c'est Sophie Riche !
Salut !
Et aujourd'hui elle vient vous montrer ses seins !
Nan !
Alors, elle vient vous parler de ses seins ?
Oui !
Elle vient vous parler de ses seins!
[Musique d'Intro de la Chaine]
Sophie Riche est une Youtubeuse, Chroniqueuse, Auteur et Comédienne.
Julien: Sophie Riche, Bonjour !
Sophie: Bonjour !
Julien: Alors, quelle est ta particularité à toi ?
Sophie: Alors, moi j'ai été opérée des seins, et du coup j'ai des grosses cicatrices.
Julien: Est-ce que tu te souviens du jour ou tu as pris conscience que tu avais quelque chose de différent ?
Sophie: Bah, c'est compliqué en fait parce que ça a commencé presque à ma naissance.
Quelques jours après ma naissance, j'ai développé un angiome
Dr: Un angiome, c'est une mal formation des vaisseaux sanguins ou lymphatiques qui sont trop dilatés,
ils peuvent avoir plusieurs formes et différentes couleurs et ils sont généralement bénins.
Généralement !
A deux-trois mois, on m'a hospitalisée parce que les médecins pensaient que c'était quelque chose de grave
Genre une tumeur
Et il se trouve qu'en fait c'était juste un angiome, et tout va bien
Mais en tout cas au moment de ma puberté, quand ma poitrine s'est développée,
On sait pas si c'est vraiment lié à l'angiome ou pas,
mais un de mes seins ne s'est pas du tout  développé comme il fallait,
et il était complètement tubulaire
C'était genre un tuyau, pas creux, mais comme une sorte de poire, mais fine à la base
Une courgette, un peu.
Julien : Un seul? Et l'autre?
Sophie : L'autre se développait plutôt normalement, mais il avait quand même une sorte de...
c'était pas 100% nikel quoi.
Dr: un sein qui se développe en forme de tube on appelle ça un sein tubéreux ou tubulaire.
C'est juste une malformation, et on ne sait pas trop pourquoi elle apparaît.
Julien : et la prise de conscience que c'était différent, tu l'as eu d'emblée quand t'as vu ta poitrine pousser?
Sophie : D'emblée, et puis surtout quand j'ai commencé à aller à la piscine avec l'école,
où là vraiment, on peut pas le cacher.
J'ai eu une puberté assez jeune, ma poitrine a commencé à pousser vers mes 8- 9 ans.
Donc les vêtements de petites filles cachent très bien au début, mais le maillot de bain très moulant, pas du tout par contre.
Donc là j'ai réalisé que ça se voyait, que les autres le voyaient.
Donc non seulement j'étais complexée parce que j'avais de la poitrine avant tout le monde,
Mais en plus j'avais une poitrine vraiment asymétrique,
C'est normal d'avoir une poitrine asymétrique, mais là c'était flagrant.
Julien : Et comment t'as réagi quand tu t'es rendue compte qu'il y avait cette différence?
Disons que c'est bizarre, parce que comme je grandissais comme ça,
à la fois ça faisait partie de moi, et en même temps je complexais beaucoup
Mais est-ce que je complexais à ce point parce que ma poitrine était vraiment asymétrique ou pas, je sais pas,
mais en tout cas le fait est que je complexais énormément sur mon corps entier.
J'étais aussi un peu en surpoids... (Beaucoup, en fait)
L'avantage que j'ai eu c'est que mes parents, très vite, m'ont dit :
"si tu complexes, si tu te sens pas bien, on va t'aider, y a une opération qui existe,
et une fois que ta croissance sera terminée, tu pourras te faire opérer et avoir une poitrine plus symétrique"
Julien : Et donc c'est le choix que tu as fais, t'as voulu te faire opérer?
Sophie : Oui, j'ai grandis avec cette idée là, en me disant que clairement que me sens pas trop bien dans mon corps,
J'osais même pas imaginer, quand "j'essayais" de flirter avec des garçons de mon lycée,
et que j'imaginais l'acte sexuel, je pouvais pas imaginer retirer mon soutif,
parce que je portais des soutiens gorges très rembourrés, pour cacher la différence de taille et de forme.
Pour moi c'était pas concevable.
Je comprends qu'il y ait des gens qui fassent le choix de garder leur particularité physique telle qu'elle est,
moi j'ai choisis de... une opération existait pour arranger ça, j'ai fait banco !
Julien : et comment tu l'as vécu l'après opération? Pour toi ça était quelque chose qui t'a libérée?
Euh... Non, parce que j'étais toujours aussi complexée
et vers 15-16 ans je me suis rendue compte que c'était pas le seul complexe que j'avais,
et que j'allais avoir une relation un peu difficile avec mon corps pour des raisons diverses
de type yo-yo, de type troubles du comportement alimentaire.
Donc j'étais soulagée d'avoir au moins ce problème réglé,
Mais en même temps je me disais qu'il y avait sacrément du boulot pour que t'acceptes tout le reste.
Julien : Cette particularité là, elle a disparu, y en a une autre qui est apparue : les cicatrices.
Et ça aujourd'hui, comment tu l'a vécu déjà dans un premier temps?
Sophie : Les cicatrices je les vis très bien
Alors effectivement au début elles étaient vraiment très rouges et très gonflées
mais on m'avait donnée une pommade en me disant qu'il fallait que je les masse régulièrement,
que je masse mes seins régulièrement pour atténuer les cicatrices
Pour le coup elles sont là, en gros y a une cicatrice autour du téton, puis verticale, puis en dessous
(sur chacun des seins)
Et donc c'est là, c'est juste plus pâle et un peu plus gonflé que le reste
Je sais que je pourrais me faire retirer ou atténuer ça encore plus au laser
Julien : ça pique le laser
Sophie: J'ai l'impression, oui
Mais j'en n'ai pas forcément envie
pas parce que j'ai peur d'avoir mal, mais plus parce que...
En fait un jour on m'a dit que les cicatrices ça raconte une histoire
et c'est vrai que moi c'est mon histoire, même si c'est pas une histoire rocambolesque
genre j'ai pas arrêté un bus avec mes seins pour sauver une colonie de vacances, ou ce genre de chose,
c'est pas un geste héroïque, c'est juste j'ai complexé sur quelque chose, j'ai été opérée pour ça,
et maintenant je complexe beaucoup moins.
J'aime bien mes seins comme ils sont, ils sont pas parfaits, ils ont des petites balafres,
mais je les aime bien.
Julien : comment ça s'est passé et comment ça se passe aujourd'hui?
Entre l'opération qui a eu lieu quand j'avais 16 ans,
et le début de ma vie sexuelle, et donc du moment où j'ai montré mes seins,
il s'est passé deux ans et demi
et donc les cicatrices se sont atténuées,
et donc j'ai vraiment eu le temps de m'habituer à ça,  et d'assumer, et de les accepter
et du coup le fait que je les ai à ce point acceptées
ça a fait que, même si ça a fait quelques petites réflexions dans la tête de mes partenaires,
je les ai pas ressenti ou ça m'a pas blessée,
La plupart du temps on m'a juste demandé : "comment ça se fait que t'as des cicatrices?"
Pas que ce soit moche ou ce genre de chose, mais juste comment ça se fait.
Et je répond toujours sans problèmes.
Julien: Et tu prends pas les devants, tu en parles pas avant?
Sophie : ça a dû m'arriver d'en parler avant, mais en vrai non...
J'ai pas forcément envie, j'aurais peur de dramatiser le truc, que dans la tête de l'autre ça fasse genre :
"elle a des rillettes à la place des seins quoi..."
J'ai tendance à tout tourner en négatif, genre quand je parle de la Picardie (d'où je viens) ,
les gens ont l'image de Germinal dans la tête parce que j'en rajoute trois tonnes sans le faire exprès,
donc j'ai pas envie de faire ça avec mon corps en fait
Julien : c'est quoi les soucis qui te restent par rapport à ta malformation initiale?
Les soucis c'est que comme l'opération... Ils m'ont ouvert le sein genre comme ça, comme une escalope
qu'on veut fourrer avec des petites herbes
J'ai plus de sensibilité, 'fin j'en retrouve depuis quelques temps,
mais sinon on me donne un coup dans les seins, je sens pas,
on me stimule les seins, je sens pas,
c'est pas du tout une zone hérogène de mon corps.
Julien : t'as plus de sensibilité au toucher, est-ce que tu considères tes seins comme une partie sexualisée de ton corps,
ou tu les as laissés de coté? Genre "je sens plus rien, ils sont pas là"
Non, parce que même si moi je sens rien, je vois bien dans le regard de mes partenaires que c'est le cas,
et comme l'acte c'est "on donne et on reçoit"
moi je pense que si, c'est une partie sexualisée de mon corps.
Julien : Au moins dans un premier temps, pour t'accepter, est-ce que quelqu'un t'a donné un très bon conseil, le meilleur conseil qu'on ai pu te donner,
et dont tu t'en souviennes?
Franchement, non.
Je sais pas comment j'ai fait pour accepter aussi bien le truc
Mais j'ai pas l'impression qu'on m'ait donné LE conseil qui a fait "tilt"
ça s'est fait hyper naturellement,
Je crois que les personnes que je pourrais le plus remercier, c'est vraiment mes parents,
qui ont dédramatisé le truc en me disant que je pouvais me faire opérer, mais que si je le faisais pas, y'aurait pas de soucis
Ca a été le truc qui a fait que je les ai beaucoup moins considérés comme un problème que ce que j'aurais pu penser
Julien: Si tu devais donner un conseil à des jeunes filles qui nous regardent et qui ont
une asymétrie ou des cicatrices, ou une particularité qui fait que leur poitrine ne ressemble pas à
l'image qu'on se fait de la poitrine classique,
toi si t'avais un conseil à leur donner, ce serait quoi?
Sophie  : Sachez qu'il y a vraiment une solution pour reformer la poitrine, pour leur donner
une petite tête de petite pastèque ou de petite clémentine
parce que dans mon cas c'est plutôt des clémentines
qu'il y a une opération qui existe. J'ai pas souffert, vraiment,
l'opération s'est déroulée parfaitement bien,
je devais passer 4 jours à l'hôpital, ça se passait tellement bien qu'au bout de 2 jours ils m'ont dit "tu peux rentrer chez toi"
mais si vous vous sentez pas de vous faire opérer, si vous voulez rester comme la nature vous a permis d'être,
et ben c'est pas grave en fait, chaque corps est tellement différent,
moi j'ai pas fait l'opération pour ressembler à tout le monde, j'ai fait l'opération parce que je ne me sentais pas de ne pas la faire
j'avais envie d'avoir une poitrine plus "tradi"
Même si elle ressemble un peu à Albator maintenant
Je dramatise là, quand je dis qu'elle ressemble à Albator?
Parce que c'es pas du tout le cas, c'est un bon exemple...
Les solutions existent, mais elles sont pas indispensables, c'est à soi de réfléchir à
comment on a envie que notre corps soit, et comment on  a envie d'être, et comment on se sent bien, ce genre de choses...
Et de toutes manières les partenaires s’accommodent de tout, parce que... c'est comme ça quoi...
Julien : Merci Sophie Riche
Sophie:  Mais je t'en prie